bonsoir à tous et merci nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 débat
mieux vivre ensemble grâce aux
éco-quartiers ses nouveaux projets
d'urbanisme aux objectifs
environnementaux sociaux et économiques
qui séduisent de plus en plus de villes
en france que le département des
yvelines
aussi sûr sur cette nouvelle façon de
concevoir le développement urbain faire
participer les usagers et les rendre
acteurs des projets dynamiser les villes
adopter une démarche plus respectueuse
et soucieuse de l'environnement apporter
des solutions face aux inégalités
sociales
les éco quartiers sont ils donc les
villes de demain est une solution
durable c'est le débat du jour et en
plateau ce soir avec nous xavier de la
porte
animateur du club climat énergie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et jérôme
bureau directeur général des services de
la ville du perray-en-yvelines bonsoir à
tous les deux sur ce plateau
alors tout d'abord pour commencer ce
débat sur l'emploi même du terme
écoquartier est ce que tout le monde est
d'accord sur ce que doit être un
écoquartier scientifique promoteur
shipwrecked politique je connais
commencez par vous à gerber très
franchement je ne pense pas je ne pense
pas c'est une notion qui est un petit
peu chaud peu dans l'esprit de beaucoup
de personnes
on le voit notamment auprès des
particuliers on a lancé ya pas très
longtemps une concertation une
participation au niveau des citoyens et
la notion d'éco quartier c'est une
notion qui n'est absolument pas maîtrisé
par le quidam de base donc il faut quand
même imaginer que le quidam de base
souvent ça donne un élu tout simplement
parce qu'il ya un élu est issu de la
société civile et c'est une notion que
beaucoup d'élus n'ont pas même donc
finalement là cette notion on y met un
peu ce qu'on veut il ya un peu de
fantasmes un peu de rêve un peu de
réalité
mais c'est pas quelque chose qui évite
clairement définies dans l'esprit de
beaucoup de personnes vous êtes d'accord
là par mois je suis effectivement tout à
fait d'accord je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de nos sens du marketing
aujourd'hui c'est un mot qui est très
porteur qui évidemment rejoint les
aspirations de beaucoup d habitants
encore faudra-t-il à l'intérieur m
exacte précise et ce qu'on appelle un
éco quartier est aujourd'hui même tout
simplement la définition les
écoquartiers n'est pas clair il donc ça
laisse la marge de manoeuvre alors à la
limite ça peut être intéressant aussi
ont essaimé très d'être un peu mieux
préciser s conserve un petit peu
peut-être ce round mode ou est ce que
c'est réellement un projet d'avenir un
projet durable
moi en tant que représentant des
collectivités locales c'est clairement
un projet d'avenir
la proche qu'on a au titre de la commune
c'est vraiment finalement la
transformation écologique numérique
énergétique de la commune et entend
casser correspond à un vrai projet de
deux politiques d'hommes politiques fins
politiques et en tant que tel ça
correspond à une vraie réalité
maintenant
d'une commune à l'autre les perceptions
était vraiment être vraiment différente
on a une variabilité sur cette notion là
qui est encore une fois très très forte
la question du numérique dans
l'éco-quartier par exemple c'est un
point qui est très peu développée
aujourd'hui
or c'est un point qui à mon avis est
tellement crucial parce que ça pose la
question de l'évaluation
l'aviation de l'éco quartier est-ce que
lui raison on est bien sûr une éco
quartier est-ce que trois quatre ans
après on est toujours sur nico quartier
est-ce que dix ans après on est toujours
c'est un écoquartier les usages ont
changé notamment au niveau des habitants
ce qui veut dire qu'il faut vraiment à
se poser la question de l'évaluation
moment la conception d'un éco quartier
et ça malheureusement ça ne peut passer
que par l'outil numérique et cet outil
n'est pas du tout maîtrisée au niveau
des collectivités locales c'est pour ça
qu'on a aussi que ce flou c'est que
finalement dans le résultat qui est
attendu il ya dix mille choses en vérité
et xavier de la porte sur sa sur la
durabilité d'un écoquartier qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez blanc c'est un enjeu
très fort je vais revenir un peu sur ce
que vous disent effectivement
l'écoquartier aujourd'hui puisque je
pensais pas clairement défini il ya un
enjeu du numérique qui majore ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'un écoquartier
c'est une brique de la smart city alors
vas pas te parler de deux villes
intelligentes et numériques doucement et
comme c'est un croisement se croisent au
des technologies de l'information des
communications avec le sol développement
des quartiers durables durable dans le
temps mais ça veut dire quoi durable ça
veut dire qu'est ce qu'on va mettre
comme technologie qu'est ce qu'on
remette au système de formation
quelles sont les données que l'on a on
aura envie maintenant partager hélas ce
prochain sont deux questions qui se sont
déjà posés au titre des systèmes
d'information qui finalement aujourd'hui
rejoignent les stratégies de
développement de la smart city où la
ville intelligente et donc des
écoquartiers et là il ya vraiment
beaucoup à faire et surtout la croisée
de beaucoup de savoir-faire
d'entreprises de collectivités des lieux
publics d'accord et aussi également
d'académie il faut pas oublier que les
entreprises et
les académiques les écoles doivent
travailler ensemble pour favoriser
l'innovation de nouveaux projets autour
des technologies d'information et de
communication et inclure les citoyens
dans ces projets là est-ce que c'est
vital aussi c'est important ça fait
partie d'une composante majeure de ce
que doit être un éco quartier totalement
je pense que le succès d'un écoquartier
cet apport l'appropriation du quartier
par ses habitants je pense que ce qui
doit fonder un écoquartier c'est d'abord
la notion d' usage si j'ai évoqué la
question de l'évaluation c'est justement
parce que les usa change
un exemple typique là aujourd'hui on est
à l'aube d'une révolution aka mobilité
notamment de véhicules autonomes cas
l'impact va être qu'elle va avoir ce
type de véhicule dans nos modes de vie
quotidien c'est une vraie question
et ce à une question qui en lien direct
avec le projet d'urbanisme liés à l'éco
quartier notamment sur la question du
stationnement
si demain on bascule manière sensible
sur le véhicule autonome
ça veut dire qu'on va avoir des
surcapacités stationnement et donc il
faut concevoir dès maintenant une
possibilité d'évolution des parcs de
stationnement vers autre chose
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut arriver à
se projeter et un éco quartier n'est
viable que s'il est évolutif et ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas encore je
pense complètement bien compris dans
l'ain dans la logique et l'évolution et
les buts
le caractère évolutif est directement
liée finalement la notion d' usage vous
avez évolué nous évoluons nous évoluons
dans notre façon de fonctionner n'est
qu'à voir sur les modes de god de
consommation aujourd'hui on ne consomme
pas aujourd'hui comment consommer il ya
dix ans au temps où il ya 50 ans
internet et la ville est passée par là
et je suis incapable de vous dire dans
15 ans comment continuera à vivre
donc voilà les deux coupes du coup ça
veut dire qu'il faut des débats prévoir
une certaine forme de souplesse dans la
notion d'éco quartier mais ça rend
encore une fois la question de
l'évaluation permanente pour adapter ça
coûte plus cher de de lancer un projet
d'écoquartier groupe à xavier de lapin
alors tout dépend encore une fois ce que
l'on va mettre dans un projet
d'écoquartier encore une ambition minime
quand on peut voir une ambition
extrêmement mobilisant avec de beaucoup
d'innovation il est clair que lorsqu'on
va mettre beaucoup d'innovations ça peut
effectivement coûté un peu plus frais
peut être un frein on pas à
l'élaboration d'un écoquartier dans une
commune par exemple
honnêtement je ne crois pas je ne crois
pas parce que c'est vraiment l'ouverture
vers de nouveaux projets et qui sont
intéressants mais je touche la
psychologie les bus là pour le coup est
aussi psychologique l'opérateur
je suis pas tout à fait avoir
effectivement parce qu'il ya une raison
toute simple c'est que aujourd'hui les
promoteurs aménageurs sont quand même
dans un schéma relativement classique et
non pas encore complètement intégré ces
nouvelles logiques notamment liés au
numérique
c'est quand même très fort parce que
dans les discussions qu'on peut avoir
justement pour la conception du quartier
il ya des idées on sent que ça bouge
mais
on a mené une autre opération est à peu
près 50 cela on en était même pas du
ciment en fait on parler d'éco quartier
meyssan revient sur ce qu'on s'était au
départ donc il ya des freins
psychologiques
parce que ça oblige finalement revoir
son mode de pensée sur cette conception
de ce que doit être la ville et sur
l'interprétation entre l'interrelation
entre ce quartier et le reste de la
commune on peut pas faire quelque chose
de magnifique dans un coin très à la
pointe de la technologie de
l'environnement du social et autres sans
prendre en compte le schéma général de
la commune sans prendre en compte la
totalité des territoires donc il faut
faire aussi évoluer le territoire mais
ça on touche tout de suite à des
habitudes des usages qui ne sont pas
encore entrés complètement dans les
moeurs sur xavier de la porte sur ça
justement la france est quand même en
retard sur à l'élaboration de cet
urbanisme nouveau comment est-ce qu'on
peut généraliser ces projets sur le
territoire français aujourd'hui du maire
générale tous les nouveaux quartiers
sont plutôt une volonté d'aller vers des
écoquartiers peut-être plus un problème
vraiment d'ambitions j'insiste beaucoup
parce qu'on peut faire beaucoup plus
qu'on ne le pense aujourd'hui la
question à savoir comment on fait que
les modes opératoires et je pense que
l'écoquartier vous l'avais dit je
m'inscris totalement la de lancer
d'abord aussi d'interroger le citoyen
c'est vraiment de se concentrer sur les
usages parce que finalement l'éco
quartier et demain la relation avec la
ville intelligente c'est de se poser la
question est ce qu'on travaille pour les
industriels ou pour une technologie ou
est-ce qu'on travaille pour l'habitant
est finalement l éco quartiers et demain
sont les larges et la ville intelligente
c'est vraiment de répondre d'abord aux
habitants ils sont demandeurs ils sont
demandeurs et il ya des modes
opératoires qui peuvent être extrêmement
innovant dans laquelle on va de plus en
plus impliqué l'écosystème et donc les
entreprises d où des territoires parce
qu'elles ont vraiment des technologies à
faire partager
et des fois les modes le mode de
fonctionnement sont aussi également
inventé sur la durabilité des
écoquartiers on peut s'interroger sur
l'utilisation peut être des maths
rio de la technologie utilisée
oui alors on revient forcément sur les
matériaux un peu plus classique
qui ont été abandonnés pendant quelques
décennies ce terreau le bois la terre
cuite les torchis ce genre de choses on
fait des matériaux qui finalement ont
été utilisés pendant des siècles par nos
ancêtres nos anciens
après
le problème c'est que ça interroge sur
les modes de construction et ses modes
de construction ont connu une évolution
d'un de formes d'industrialisation qui a
mis de côté un certain nombre de process
donc il faut réinventer ses process même
s'ils ne sont pas complètement perdu
mais il faut les réinventer dans le
cadre d'un modèle économique parce qu'il
faut ne pas oublier une chose c'est
qu'il ya un écoquartier c'est aussi
avant tout une question d'argent
ça a été un petit peu le sens de la
question tout à l'heure un bâtiment qui
sur une durée de vie de 50 ans
la construction du bâtiment c'est
seulement 25 % du coût total du bâtiment
sur ses 50 ans il ya 75 % qui sont liées
aux frais d'exploitation
donc là la qualité du matériau utilisé
la conception architecturale les
éléments de deux encore une fois de
dévaluation de ce bâtiment dans sa vie
sont sous tous ces aspects là sont très
important parce que c'est vraiment
l'accompagnement du bâtiment dans son
existence derrière et dans sa gestion
courante
demain donc vivre à tous dans un
écoquartier est-ce que sk les anciens
quartiers enseigne construction sont
prises en compte du coût dans
l'élaboration la structuration d'un
écoquartier si on imagine que demain on
sera tous dans un écoquartier on démolit
tout pour reconstruire ou connaissez
sûrement ça vient de l'annoncer sûrement
mais parfois peut-être fait faut être
honnête qui est des moments donnés ou
peut se poser qui s'ouvre à nous si on
n'a pas plus intérêt à démolir alors va
pas rentrer dans des modèles économiques
mais ça se calcule il faut aussi et le
bien comprendre que on parle de
durabilité donc on parle du temps et on
parle aussi de consommation d'énergie or
aujourd'hui les modèles énergétiques
sont pas des sujets faciles à aborder
d'ailleurs ils sont très mal abordé la
plupart du temps avec une consommation
d'énergie croissante ne serait ce que
pour dire que en vingt ans par exemple
on a réduit en pourcentage la
consommation d'énergie à base de lait de
fossiles de seulement 10% nous passer de
80 % à 70 % sur une base européenne que
ça veut dire que les progrès en termes
de consommation d'énergie et donc
d'énergie fossiles sont encore majeur or
pour ce faire peut-être que les
technologies anciennes aujourd'hui il
faut vraiment se poser des questions
entre le coup la rénovation ce qu'on
parle de bâtiments et le coût du neuf
alors je dis pas que c'est simple mais
le coup est majeur et le coup l'énergie
étant sous-évalué alors je fais
attention à ce que je dis aujourd'hui il
ne peut qu'évoluer une montée de manière
significative
je pense que la question énergétique est
vraiment centrale
l'évolution des quartiers l'éco quartier
ou pas pour quand même voir une chose
c'est qu'il ya un paradigme qui est en
train de changer c'est la question du
véhicule électrique
il ya eu un certain nombre d'annoncés
qui ont été faites au niveau
international la chine a prévu de
basculer tout son parc de poses d'engins
thermique en électrique
c'est un signal très très fort mais
l'industriel la france elle-même
s'engage dans une transition électrique
très très forte sur ce qui est à ces
questions là mais ne serait-ce que paris
madame hidalgo a annoncé le tout
électrique je crois heureusement 2030 ou
2025 je ne sais plus exactement ça si
effectivement c'est ce calendrier
respecté ça veut dire que en fait tout
le mode de fonctionnement tous deux de
la mobilité qu'on connaît aujourd'hui va
disparaître on va forcément passer sur
autre chose
or là on a une problématique majeure
notamment en france c'est la production
d'énergie la production d'énergie
aujourd'hui on a un système qui est lié
au nucléaire très largement même si la
part énergie renouvelable augmente mais
le développement du parc de véhicules
électriques va considérer
considérablement changé la donne sur les
questions de production
mais aujourd'hui les pendant ce mois les
tendances qu'on voit c'est finalement on
commence à privilégier finalement la
production locale l'opérateur
énergétique
là ça c'est un vrai sujet et dans le cas
des réhabilitations ça va être un point
technique important ce sera le mot de la
fin à messieurs shenhav on n'a plus le
temps de débattre sur cette thématique
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur ce
plateau c'est la fin si cette huile
débat ce soir consacrée aux éco
quartiers
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet et a commenté vous le savez sur
les réseaux sociaux
bonne soirée et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]